[Musique]
nous ne rentrerons chez nous que si le
gouvernement nous donne des terres qui
change les lois ou qu'ils nous jettent
en prison
dans 20 ans leur pays sera la cinquième
puissance économique du monde mais à
quel prix ça c'est de la bauxite c'est
pour prendre cette pierre que
l'entreprise veut nous chasser de la
colline sacré déplacés de force exclus
de la croissance parce qu'ils
appartiennent aux basses castes les
oubliées du miracle indien se soulève
chaque jour je me demande pourquoi dieu
nous a fait ainsi alors que d'autres
sont si riches
emmenés par celui qu'ils surnomment le
nouveau gandhi ils vont marcher 350
kilomètres du centre de l'inde jusqu'à
new delhi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toutes les terres disponibles doivent
être distribués aux pauvres de ce pays
et seulement s'il en reste se donner les
aux industriels
en 1930 déjà guidé par gandhi le peuple
indien s'étaient dressés contre le
pouvoir le mahatma avait lui aussi
parcouru 350 km lors d'une marche
pacifique parvenu à l'océan il avait
pris dans ses mains ce celle que les
britanniques interdisait aux indiens de
ramasser
[Musique]
ce 2 octobre 2007 les héritiers du
mahatma se réunissent à gwalior bastion
historique de la résistance aux anglais
ils vont marcher pour leurs terres en 26
jours il espère à leur tour faire
basculer l'histoire
[Musique]
garrel guaino
quand j'étais jeune il y avait des
chevreuils des lièvres et pigeon vert
beaucoup d'espèces et est ici en
abondance
il y a de moins en moins d'animaux dans
la jungle
le gouvernement les a tous prêts pour le
parc de cana il a ruiné notre jungle
à plus de 1000 km de new delhi
la forêt des bayas est perdue au milieu
des collines de cana en plein centre de
l'inde
elle jouxte la plus grande réserve
d'animaux sauvages du sous continent
le gouvernement souhaite agrandir le
parc pour satisfaire une industrie
touristique en plein essor
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya des
empreintes de tigres
et vous avez vu le tigre non juste les
empreintes
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir ici
jds bhutan du sida c'est la bonne heure
pour voir les tigres ou parce qu'ils
peuvent chasser le soir
cinq mille visiteurs en 2006 dix mille
en 2007 au parc national de cana il est
désormais plus probable de croiser des
touristes que des tigres qu'importe dans
les circuits des tour opérators ce
safari et l'activité phare garantie inde
authentiques
sont les touristes qui résident dans
notre lunch certains safari le matin et
l'après midi on les emmène voir du
village et
ils peuvent rencontrer des habitants
il ya on les emmener en promenade
découverte cependant
il ya des gens qui vivent dans
l'enceinte du parc non les 27 villages
aborigènes ont été réimplantés avec
succès du parking
en réalité la tribu de chez caris bigard
n'a pas été réimplantée elle a été
évacuée manu militari pour laisser place
aux touristes
avant mais red et but partout ici elles
ont été détruites l'an dernier et nous
avons été expulsés du village
[Musique]
moi ma maison était ici
les policiers sont venus par surprise il
ne nous avait pas prévenus
ils sont venus sans uniforme avec le
commissaire ils m'ont dit dégage d'ici à
installer ailleurs
chez caris a déménagé pour la quatrième
fois et le parc a tourist a englouti son
ancienne maison à deux pas de sa hutte
sous ses yeux un lodge 5 étoiles sort de
terre chaabi les clés traitement apporté
clé des champs dentaire et aux
doigts ramasse les poubelles autour des
arbres qu'on voit pas ça sur le fil
le patron arrive tout juste de new delhi
où il dirigeait un palace
et a donc sommes les premiers à adapter
le concept de la suite un lot de 4 suite
500 dollars la nuit safari inclus
l'économie est en plein boom
beaucoup d'entreprises étrangères
s'installe en inde
elles recherchent ce type de prestation
donc ce n'est plus un luxe mais une
nécessité pour l'élite les
multinationales et les touristes
étrangers
les rares bahia qui reste dans
l'enceinte du parc donc deux
possibilités
travaillé comme ouvrier sur les
chantiers ou danser pour les touristes
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée pour distraire ses
pensionnaires le patron du lunch
convoque quelques membres de la tribu
[Musique]
dans les villages qui entoure le parc la
nouvelle s'est répandue l'été dernier
des tribus se réunissaient pour marcher
vers la capitale et défendre leur terre
chez caris & portés volontaires pour
représenter les maïga il partira cet
après midi avec ses parents
[Musique]
donne moi une assiette
une tasse pour l'eau
et un vêtement
il me faut aussi une écharpe au cas où
il ferait froid la nuit
rabbit hole est tu veux pas pleurer non
la loi
non tu vas jouer oui
quand
dans la marche sera terminé
probablement dans un mois peut-être plus
je ne rentrerai pas avant que nos
requêtes soient satisfaites je serai
peut-être jeté en prison mais je ne
renoncerai pas alors fais attention aux
enfants qu'ils n'aillent pas trop loin
dans la colline du grave
car donner un beau gars est un
autrement dit
ah
bon
lesquels et au cambodge
la
dame était là
et
voilà
d
sur le
je
au premier jour ils sont quelques
milliers
les plus déterminés ce qui se prépare
depuis des mois à porter le message de
leur tribu ou de leur caste
[Musique]
c'est normal
allez
il a fallu plus de deux jours de voyage
h et carrie et ses parents pour
rejoindre la marche
à pied en camion puis entra
[Musique]
maintenant qu'on est là on ira jusqu'au
bout on marchera jusqu'à notre dernier
souffle of may bowles et si on doit
mourir ce serait au pied du palais du
gouvernement
cette marche c'est la dernière ligne
droite alors rien ne peut nous arrêter
mon père a raison et vaut mieux mourir à
delhi en résistant plutôt que de rester
chez nous à ne rien faire
dans une inde en pleine expansion il
demande un minimum de terre à cultiver
pour les plus pauvres l'homme qui les a
réunis aujourd'hui sur cette route est
un simple travailleur social converti
depuis peu à une méthode d'action
radical inspiré de gandhi la
désobéissance civile
aujourd'hui ceux qui depuis si longtemps
courbe l'échiné vont enfreindre la loi
leur marche bloquera l'autoroute qui
mène à la capitale
on ne te baise pas avançons
il faut pas ralentir la marche
ne vous baissez pas pour moi
il aura fallu deux ans à rajagopal pour
fédérer les tribus dépossédés de leurs
terres et les milliers de communautés
d'intouchables
après 60 ans d'indépendance pourquoi des
gens sont réduits à marcher ainsi
parce que le gouvernement ne leur donne
pas les moyens de vivre
ça me rend triste et honteux d'en
arriver là mais en même temps je suis
fier de ces pauvres gens qui refusent
enfin de s'abaisser et vont se battre
[Musique]
hahaha
premier arrêt après 15 km par plus de 35
degrés
[Musique]
toutes les nuits pendant un mois les
marcheurs dormiront à même le bitume
le soir venu rajagopal réuni les
représentants de chaque état pour
décider de la stratégie à suivre
le gouvernement doit nous respecter nous
sommes trop puissant pour qu ils nous
ignorent
sa délicate
calqué meeting après notre réunion
voyons ce cas là nous proposer et il
faut que l'on sache vite ce gel des
prêts à accepter tous d'accord
pour l'instant depuis que l'on a
commencé la marche je ne connais pas
leurs positions
moi j'ai eu les gens du ministère au
téléphone aujourd'hui et ils n'ont rien
dit il faut que l'on réagisse vite
certains quais en fonction de leurs
réponses
déciderons si nous durci sur le
mouvement ou non à neige ont en tout cas
dormir sur la route ça du charmant
j'ai peur qu'une fois la marche terminé
on se soient tous habitués à dormir
dehors
quittera nos maisons pour vivre sur les
routes
alors
[Musique]
de la bauxite
là encore
là là là aussi
il y en a partout tout autour
c'est ça qui retient toute l'eau de la
rivière
si l'entreprise devait dans ta bien
nouveau les sept bauxite la rivière sera
à sec comment ferons nous alors pour
vivre
à 700 km à l'est du parcours de la
marche lusine vedanta est implanté au
pied de la colline de niort guiry elle
appartient à un groupe anglais le site
regorge de bauxite dont est issue la nu
mines et l'industrialisation indienne
est dévoreuse de minerais le terrain a
été attribué à l'entreprise en quelques
jours bientôt il sera classé parmi les
140 zone économique spéciale du pays des
sites c'est libre de taxes réservé à
l'industrie
personne n'a demandé leur avis aux
dongria kondh la tribu qui peuplent la
colline
ça c'est un gros bof
je dois pas avoir la benauge
sur le jeu n'arrive pas le bouger
si l'exploitation de minerais se
poursuit les 8000 aborigènes seront
déplacées de force
elles ont aidé à cette partie on va la
manger tout de suite à l'eau et l'autre
où va la conserver on va se régaler
durer des mois alors vous en êtes où
m jeudi que la peau les nantais mais
vous y prenez comme des manches a dit
qu'il va me chercher de quoi cuisiner au
lieu de faire des remarques et je suis
pas ta bonne calme-toi et dépêche toi il
va faire sombre
c'est ton problème si tu veux manger du
boeuf la
confidente à est arrivé ici et nous ont
proposé de l'argent pour qu'on quitte
notre colline mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire avec de l'argent on va perdre
notre dignité béthune talent gouttes
trois kilomètres plus bas tout est déjà
prêt pour le déplacement de gâteaux maji
et des habitants du village
tu as vu les barras que vedanta a
construit pour nous ils croient qu'on va
s'en passer là dedans un souk et
adam bois aulas commence à sousse à chez
même pu ouvrir une porte égard
regarde y'a même pas de fenêtre avec des
petits trous
on peut à peine respirer attisé et ils
nous prennent vraiment pour des
imbéciles vie on y voit abdoulaye issa
grandes ou petites de toute façon ne
vivra jamais dans ces maisons comme
comment faire avec nos six chèvres là
dedans et si on a des invités pour le
moule au ghetto où on leur fait à manger
jamais je n'habite réussi boukai de wana
pour bâtir cette usine il a fallu
abattre deux mille hectares de forêt et
déplacé plus de 100 familles
elles ont été relogées par vedanta dans
un village modèle
d'autres suivent elle raconté que tu
travailles la viens avec moi quand aider
à enfin
et là ça je vous présente monsieur 10 u
13 17 matchs et il est employé chez nous
et
compagnie il fait partie des familles
qui ont déjà été déplacées
les vases ils racontent leur ton
histoire
veut l'entendre dire que tout va bien
donc tu leur dis que tout va bien qu'il
y à une école un hôpital à disposition
depuis que nous sommes lâchés heureux
nous sommes soigner nous avons des
médicaments nous travaillons dans de
très bonnes conditions et c'est le cas
de tout le monde ici
voici une première chambre il y en a
deux en tout
ils peuvent regarder la télévision
des portables pour pouvoir communiquer
rapidement kessel ils produisent des
motos même des voitures et des 4 4 avec
alfortville as l'air ils ont un terrain
de jeux pour s'amuser pour jouer au
volley ball au foot et au cricket
il a un téléphone portable vous pouvez
bien sûr il a un portable il va vous le
montrez moi plutôt téléphone
contrat
il est content d'avoir un téléphone tu
as bien consentir est content
il dit qu'il est très content que son
portable parce que le réseau est très
bon
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes au courant de ce qui se passe
dans la colline de niambly les
populations tribales qui ne veulent pas
être déplacé
arrêter ça
mon directeur vient de téléphoner pour
dire que je n'ai pas le droit de parler
de ça une folle pascal soto arrêtez s'il
vous plaît vous n'avez pas droit non non
non
20 dongria kondh s'apprête à rejoindre
la marche ils quitteront la colline de
nième guéri pour la première fois
tout le monde est en train de nous
tromper parce qu'on est des tribaux
parce qu'on est il est très con ne
connaît rien aux papiers qu'ils nous
font lire
si on ne se bat pas on finira par tout
perdre basset
nous allons marcher pour honorer notre
dieu d'acolytes à nîmes radja boulet
c'est lui qui nous donne la force de
nous mettre à l'honneur comme il est
très en colère aujourd'hui doté d'une
âme d'homme tout ceci nous n'allons pas
à new delhi il finira par nous manger
qui donna
tu as vu il ya même des lits pour dormir
non content quand je vois tout ça je
suis triste je ne vois personne qui
travaille comme saint-quentin qu'il n'y
a pas d'arbres où trouve-t-il leurs
fruits pour manger
il n'y a pas de mendier d'orange et de
grenadiers je ne vois rien et comment
est-il possible de vivre ici je ne
pourrai jamais quitté ma copine
20 heures de train une nuit de bus et
les dongria kondh rejoignent les
marcheurs
on a
du talent
je ne pensais pas qu'il y aurait autant
de monde il ya des milliers de gens qui
ont fait le voyage ça me rend vraiment
heureuse volant bottines
oui
essaye de dégager la voie il faut pas
qu'on s'arrête
marche à 28 ans s'est lancé dans
l'action sociale pendant ses études
patientez s'il vous plaît aidez mille
personnes vont traverser
comme des centaines de jeunes indiens
issus de castes supérieures elle se bat
pour que le pays de gandhi invente un
modèle de développement respectueux de
tous
comme vous le voyez la police n'est pas
là donc je me retrouve à faire la police
pourquoi ne sont ils pas là
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas qu'on
continue
d'exister dans les moments critiques que
des masques tombent et pour le temps
passe mais comme les boules nous nous
arrêterons pas
ils n'en n'ont plus les moyens
[Musique]
ils viennent d'où tous ces jours là
ils viennent de tout le pays
les plus petits villages des quartiers
des districts
ils réclament des droits sur leurs
terres le gouvernement ne les écoute pas
alors ils ont décidé de se battre avec
cette marche
est née d'un panier de toute façon dans
ce pays c'est les riches qui ont tout
l'argent et le pouvoir à nous les
pauvres il ne reste rien l'hiver
et d'après toi c'est quoi la solution
il faut faire exploser le capitalisme
non moi je pense que c'est vous qui avez
la bonne solution tu viens avec nous au
niveau des langues et plus qu'au
prochain arrêt de la marge qui nous
accompagnent
c'est parti
et
où
ils étaient une poignée au départ ils
sont des dizaines de milliers après huit
jours de marche
la file indienne salon désormais sur 10
km
les vivres commencent déjà à manquer et
les corps souffrent sous le soleil de
plomb
écoute moi s'il te plaît mais ses
chaussures non non c'est bon j'ai
l'habitude de marcher pieds nus
mêlée je t'en prie
tu es comme ma mère
ça va pas qu'on perd allez viens avec
moi
est ce qu'il y ait un véhicule pour
l'emmener
mon frère à toi
j'ai un malade c'est sérieux s'il vous
plaît faites une place là d'accord
grand père vient est-ce qu'il ya encore
du monde derrière toi je sais pas tu es
sûr personne derrière
et dès le
du roman de la marche et tu dis que
warszawa une ambulance et tu as compris
c'est bon tu peux y aller
1 et toi grand père accroche toi
la famille halliday n'oublie je suis le
seul activiste de ma famille
qui m'a énormément influencé
à elie là vraiment je laime
je laime pour l'amour qui l'a porté à la
société a été oui je laime pour sa dent
et picasa lundi nous apprend à me battre
avec la non-violence et ex faut être
patient pour combattre ainsi
c'est très facile de prendre une arme et
de tirer sur quelqu'un c'est plus
difficile de se montrer patiente
d'élaborer une stratégie et de planifier
et
non chagos mattheeuws on l'est il n'y a
que des personnes fortes chutes qui
peuvent le faire je sais que tous ces
gens sont forts
mais du calme du calme y en aura pour
tout le monde c'est une ligne
qu'à l'aller vous avez mangé
bonjour vous allez bien
tekkari très bien vous êtes fatigué
après sept journées de matchs non c'est
vrai comment pourriez-vous être fatigué
vous êtes du chhattisgarh ceux qui
viennent du chhattisgarh sont des durs
un jour quelqu'un est venu voir qu'andy
et lui a dit il n'ya aucune révolution
non violente
regardez la révolution française la
révolution russe la révolution chinoise
dans l'histoire il n'ya aucune
révolution non violente et gandhi lui a
répondu vous êtes en train de
m'apprendre l'histoire mais moi je suis
en train de la faire et nous ici nous
écrivons aussi d'histoire regardez ces
milliers de personnes dans ce champ qui
se contentent juste d'un peu de
nourriture et qui se battent pour leurs
droits c'est ça faire l'histoire
venez ça se passe juste à côté
il y un meeting avec rajagopal à la
tribune les organisateurs de la marche
voilà voilà dit qu'on va aller l'écouter
à mi parcours les marcheurs sont si
nombreux que le gouvernement commence à
s'inquiéter
il demanda rajagopal d'interrompre le
mouvement de protestation avant new
delhi en échange d'une promesse de
réforme
ce n'est pas suffisant
les partis politiques nous ont trompés
depuis 60 ans notre marche continuera
le gouvernement doit engager
immédiatement les réformes et établir
des titres de propriété sinon nous
passerons à l'étape suivante
nous prendrons les terres de force nous
contourneront les lois
comme gandhi il ya 70 ans
[Musique]
cette nuit j'ai rêvé que je ramassais
des ordures
comme j'en avais ramasser trop je ne
savais pas comment rentrer à la maison
je n'arrivais pas à tous porter
voilà de quoi je rêve
[Applaudissements]
intouchable parmi les intouchables
rob tohra et ses huit enfants sont des
moussard littéralement des mangeurs de
rats ils vivent dans l'état le plus
pauvre d'inde le billard au nord-est du
pays
si j'avais plus de nourriture je le
rends préparerait plus ils vont sûrement
me redemande et ils ne comprendront pas
pourquoi chaleur en donne pas assez
officiellement le système des castes a
disparu en inde il subsiste dans la
pratique exclu de tous les emplois
décents les moussard ne peuvent vivre qu
en collectant les déchets qu'ils trient
et revente au kilo la dernière journée
de rock tora avant de rejoindre la
marche commence donc comme toutes les
autres par un ramassage d'ordures ce
matin il ya peu de déchets dans les rues
de patna elle gagnera moins de 20
roupies à peine 40 centimes
[Musique]
regarde cela comme elles sont belles ça
doit être au moins 10 euros
c'est là que j'aime elles sont vraiment
belles
regarde celle avec les broderies elles
sont bien aussi ça doit demander de
tellement de travail de fabriquer sa
brouette à résoudre sont belles
je suis sûr que si quelqu'un de bien
habillé tête à notre place en train de
regarder la vitrine le vendeur sera déjà
sorti avec un grand sourire pour nous
montrer ses chaussures mais nous il ne
faut pas y compter on n'est pas assez
bien habillés ils s'en fichent des
ramasseurs d'ordures
oui
le gouvernement ne fait rien pour nous
il a oublié que nous votons que nous
faisons les briques de ces maisons que
nous cultivons la terre de ce pays
nous restons pauvres juste parce que
nous sommes considérés comme des jambes
dénué d'intelligence nous n'avons pas le
droit d'étudier et nous restons tout en
bas de la société
le ramassage des ordures ne suffit pas à
nourrir ses enfants
allaient dépêcher vous coupez seriez
vous aurez de quoi manger on tour à
travail aux champs l'après midi sous les
ordres d'un contremaître
combien tu va nous donner aujourd'hui
baptiste 25 roupies et si vous
travaillez bien vous aurez un kilo de
riz aujourd'hui aller les gosses il en
faut 5 là-bas au travail
chacun à votre place retourner à votre
place
et toi tu vas là-bas
pour 16 pouces de rire amassé elles sont
payées une roupie
fatale les enfants ne gagne rien il est
seulement mais on paie les moeurs la
et regardez là le trou
je suis sûr qu'il y aura dedans
si on la trappe on va le faire cuire
c'est pour ça qu'on s'appelle les moussa
ça veut dire mon genre de
rallye a que nous qui savons faire ça
ici tout le monde sait préparer le
rallye terre des gens qui n'aiment pas
ça le mieux c'est de le faire frire
moi je rajoute des épices le meilleur
set en ragoût mois avec quatre ou cinq
rats je fais un charisme quand j'en ai
que deux jeux h la viande et on le donne
aux enfants avec des lentilles
[Musique]
si on avait juste un peu de terre vous
pourrez faire vivre tout le village
regardez comme des fertile ce champ
regardez tous leurs et qu'il ya
mais nous les moussa et nous n'avons pas
peur nous n'avons rien
les terres se transmettent de père en
fils au sein des castes supérieures
de la jusqu'au maison là-bas ce sont mes
terres pour me faire vivre seul c'est
suffisant
[Musique]
c'est grâce à cette heure que je suis
haut placés dans la société
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas sont en bas de
l'échelle sociale
ce propriétaire membres de la caste
divine des brahmanes affirme qu'il a
offert des parcelles aux mousses harkis
vivent sur ses terres
ces personnes vient de france et ils
font un film sur les riches et les
pauvres ils m'ont demandé est ce que
vous avez donné des terres à des gens
pauvres gd oui d'accord
ça se passe bien ici
nous n'avons pas de terre et nous avons
construit notre maison ici de nos mains
sur ses terres à lui
nous travaillons dans ses champs et nous
partageons avec lui des récoltes divise
en deux 2 mètres prend la moitié et nous
on garde le reste
donc vous ne lui avait pas donné de
terre
je ne lui ai pas vraiment donné
c'est juste qu'elle s'occupe de mes
shows de ma maison
ils font le travail et il mange ce qu'il
récolte
c'est comme ça
à
et oui
bah y'a des voix la mer et je pars
demain à calais attaque éclair à etsaut
mes enfants je te confie la maison il
faudra que tu t'occupes de tous
les aléas là je veux venir aussi muni il
faut que tu restes là il ya makan avait
cassé
avait fâché parce qu'elle sait que je
vais partir de là
il faut que tu trouves au téléphone si
on a besoin de toujours
attendre je ne sais pas comment je m'en
trouver
l atr fois je me dis que je ne devrais
pas y aller
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain sur le quai de la gare de
patna des dizaines de moussa art venus
d'autres villages par te rejoindre la
marche trois jours de voyage les
attendent
le train s'élance vers l'ouest sans
retour
j'ai renoncé je n'ai vraiment pas les
moyens je voulais aller à cette marche
mais la communauté mon a dit souhaiter
et non 10 comme on va suivre là bas tout
seul
et puis je suis la seule à pouvoir
m'occuper de cette maison si je pars
personne ne me remplacera
l'homme de la maison mon mari m'a
interdit de partir d'ogm a arrêté mahdi
n'y va pas
à la guerre
[Musique]
et
ce matin les drapeaux sont en berne
un camion a percuté le cortège au lever
du jour
trois marcheurs ont été tués
on hamm est à 20 h
dans ce linceul improvisé le corps d'un
paysans venus du centre de l'inde
son meilleur ami qui l'accompagnait sur
la marche va rendre sa dépouille à sa
famille
24 heures de voyage en camion vers le
sud
le corps est posée sur un simple point
de glace
mise et raciale il était à la marche
pour demander une heure
nous venons de village tribale où
l'office des forêts à confisquer de
terres ancestrales
comme jacquet
[Musique]
aïe
[Applaudissements]
à
alors
ni à
juin
m
avant d'emmener le corps du défunt les
villageois brise les bracelets de
mariages de saveurs
c'était sa maison
il laisse sept enfants
quatre filles et trois garçons sa femme
ses enfants vont devoir aller travailler
à la mine
il est parti pour défendre nos droits il
n'a même pas pu terminer la marche pas
pas dire que ça n'a servi à rien
ils rendent leur arrêt nous allons
procéder ou rituelles sur l'auteur pour
laquelle nous nous battons cette heure
que nous cultivions et que le
gouvernement veut nous enlever
les crises et les guerres c'est ici
les angels ont posé son corps
selon la croyance hindoue le père du
défunt puisqu'il meurt avant son fils
ira en enfer et il revient à son frère
aîné d' allumer le bûcher
allez courage lève toi
toi
il a sacrifié sa vie pour ses frais
si comme lui mais nous initions avec
d'autres exclus sous une même bannière
nous pouvons vaincre n'importe qui dans
le monde
l'union nous mènera à la victoire
son sacrifice doit nous rendre plus
forts
nous puisons notre énergie dans son
martyr
je lui permet de reposer en paix et
maintenant terminons le rituel en silo à
l'égal arsenault canon
[Musique]
tu as vu toutes ses routes et ses
maisons c'est beau hein
non
non alors que c'est à cause de ces gens
qui sont dedans qu'on en est réduit à
venir marcher sur la route pour l'outil
en gommant on peut trouver ça beau yvan
soulagement peut-être évolué moi tout ce
qui me motive c'est de voir tous nos
frères des tribus tous les pauvres
autour de moi avec les mêmes problèmes
à
au
fait ils demandent des emplois c'est ça
oui
[Applaudissements]
vu leur visage et leur allure s'ils sont
de castes inférieures
il crée plein d'embouteillage ça
perturbe tous les trajets tout ça pour
quoi j'en sais rien je comprends même
pas d'où viennent tous ces gens
[Musique]
chacun d'entre eux est conscient de ses
droits cela fait deux ans que nous nous
préparons pacifiquement n'étant que le
gouvernement entende notre message le
peuple devrait bénéficier du droit à une
paire diable à une existence digne
je le sors à peine
je suis convaincu que le gouvernement va
céder tout le monde a tenu bon les
femmes les enfants avaient même mon père
qui est malade il s'est fait transporter
en tête de cortège il refuse de rentrer
avant d'avoir lu les propositions du
gouvernement
on ne laissera pas aller jusqu'au
parlement c'est une question d'ordre
public
on commencera par des avertissements
ensuite on passera aux charges à coups
de bâtons
[Musique]
les policiers dirige les marcheurs vers
un terrain vague ils sont parqués à
l'écart du centre-ville
[Musique]
yahoo
bien
placez des policiers entre le peuple et
le gouvernement
c'est une méthode utilisée si souvent
dans ce pays des policiers armés de
bâtons protège des ministres ainsi que
confortablement dans leurs bureaux
climatisés devant la télévision alter et
voilà de vieilles habitudes auxquelles
vous ne devez plus vous soumettre à
tibati d'orlando
a nommé rapaces et
qualité ne
veulent pas qu'on avance l on ait eu ce
qu'on fait on ne bouge pas i look at me
jeter en prison à ta question de céder
maintenant donne des regrets
open de nourriture si le gouvernement ne
répond pas d'ici le mans 72 entameront
une grève de la faim illimitée
il devra s'organiser pour ramasser nos
cadavres
[Musique]
toute la nuit le gouvernement à chercher
une issue à la crise à 10 heures du
matin le premier ministre chargé
secrétaire d'état de présenter aux
organisateurs de la marche une liste de
propositions c'est pas de ma compétence
n'était prévenue que ce matin si c'est
votre compétence
deux heures plus tard
le gouvernement a capitulé quand même
nom le gouvernement n'a pas capitulé
g n le gouvernement accepte vos demandes
donc il n'y aura plus de déplacements
forcés de tribus
nous avons une politique d'indemnisation
et bientôt il y aura une politique en
faveur des tribus non lus de
déplacements forcés
[Applaudissements]
vous
êtes vous satisfait par ce que vient de
dire le ministre
maintenant que la loi est écrite sur le
papier ou faut-il l'écrire sur la terre
un morceau de papier ne suffit pas
c'est pourquoi après votre retour chez
vous un nouveau combat commencera
je sais que vous êtes impatients de
rentrer
[Applaudissements]
je vous félicite tous
là bravo pour cette victoire
madina
alors c'est fini on rentre
la terre sur laquelle nous avons volé
son corps va être rendue aussi loin
qu'il aille vers son homme va reposer en
paix et
l'unité du peuple a vaincu
[Applaudissements]
nous avons obtenu une promesse et nous
allons la faire respecter
le jour de leur retour à cannes 1 les
vagues étaient attendues par un
fonctionnaire de l'office des forêts
s'est engagé à délivrer des titres de
propriété aux familles
un mois après la fin de la marche la
cour suprême a donné raison à la tribu
de gâteaux maji alimente
l'usiné n'aura plus le droit d'extraire
de bauxite de la colline de niambly
s'ils ne tiennent pas leurs promesses
les tribus s'uniront et nous
recommencerons le combat
[Applaudissements]
chez les moussard la récolte de riz
s'est terminée par une maigre moisson
est une grande chasse aux rats
rajagopal varsha et tous les
organisateurs de la marche se sont
lancées dans un nouveau combat pour
l'abolition des castes en inde
[Musique]